voici le brame le cri caractéristiques
du cerf entre la mi août et la mi
octobre
c'est la période de reproduction du roi
de la forêt pour impressionner les
biches et de façon à repousser les
autres mâles lecerf pousse son brame
pour pouvoir transmettre ces gènes à
l'espace rambouillet où la grande faune
forestière gambade dans les 180 hectares
de forêt faire entendre ce phénomène
naturel aux visiteurs est un moyen de
faire de la pédagogie tout le plaisir
que les gens vont prendre ici on espère
que c'est du plaisir qu'ils vont à
prayssas répercuter sur tous les milieux
naturels qu'ils iront voir après que ça
va les inciter à sortir à venir dans les
forêts et à venir dans avec beaucoup de
respect en fait par rapport au milieu
naturel
pour répondre à cet objectif le parc
animalier forestier géré par l'office
national des forêts organise d'ailleurs
des animations dont le matin ou assez
tard le soir pendant toute la période du
brame un guide accompagne les curieux
pour aller au plus près des animaux mais
le parc est aussi ouvert toute la
journée pour qui souhaiterait partir en
quête de ce son si particulier
l'idée c'est de prendre l'air voilà
moi je ne connaissais pas l'espace
rambouillet donc ça me permet aussi de
découvrir
et puis parce que la période du brame
des cerfs donc c'est vraiment voilà mais
on y venait pour ça va un peu tous les
animaux les oublier et j'en ai déjà vu
ba des débuts et pourquoi pas des tiers
les visiteurs qui auront eu la chance ou
non d'entendre le brame pourront dans
tous les cas venir à l'espace
rambouillet observer les naissances
issues de cette période de reproduction
les petits faons devrait naître en mai
ou juin prochain